Nos preguntan, convierte la siguiente ecuación de la forma punto pendiente
a la forma pendiente intersección.
En otras palabras, si se reescribe la ecuación
en la forma "y" es igual a "mx" más "b",
¿cuáles son los valores de "m"y "b"?
Ok, y tengo esta ecuación de aquí,
"y" más 11 es igual a 5 por "x" más 2.
Así que déjame sacar por acá mi bloc de
notas, mi libreta de apuntes para poder trabajar
este problema y fíjate bien que aquí ya
tenemos esta ecuación,
"y" más 11 es igual a 5 que multiplica a
"x" más 2 y si te das cuenta,
con esta forma de escribir a la recta punto pendiente podemos fijarnos de una manera muy sencilla que ésta,
ésta de aquí es su pendiente y bueno, también
podemos fijarnos de una manera muy sencilla,
que esta recta pasa...
y déjame cambiar de color...
esta recta pasa por el punto -2, -11.
Y déjame ponerlo aquí,
pasa por el punto -2, -11.
Y esto es porque recuerda que la forma punto
pendiente se ve como la pendiente que multiplica
a "x" menos "x1" o dicho de otra manera, a
"x" menos la coordenada en "x"
del punto por el que pasa, es decir -2 por menos es más
2 y esto es igual a "y" menos "y1", es decir,
"y" menos la coordenada en "y" del punto por
el que pasa, es decir -11.
Y bueno, lo que nosotros queremos es pasar
de esta ecuación a la forma pendiente intersección
con el eje de las "y" o lo que es lo mismo,
pendiente ordenada al origen.
Y que bueno, claro, como sabemos, es de la
forma "y", es igual a "m" por "x" más "b",
ok.
Ahora, para llegar a esta forma, lo que voy
a hacer es trabajar con esta ecuación
y utilizar una manipulación algebraica
para encontrar esta
ecuación en la forma pendiente
intersección con el eje de las "y".
Y entonces seguramente te imaginarás que "m" la pendiente, seguirá siendo este 5 que tenemos aquí.
Y bueno, como te imaginarás, lo primero que vamos a hacer  es distribuir este 5 multiplicando a estos dos.
Por lo tanto, vamos a hacerlo.
Me va a quedar, "y" más 11.. "y" más 11
esto es igual a 5 por "x",
lo cual me va a dar "5x"...
déjame ponerlo así...
"5x" más 5 por 2 lo cual es 10, "5x" más 10.
Ahora, si te das cuenta estamos muy cerca
de tener la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen que queremos.
Lo único que nos hace hacer es quitar este
11 del lado izquierdo de esta ecuación
y para eso, lo que voy a hacer es restar 11
de ambos lados de esta ecuación,
de tal forma que si resto 11 de aquí y resto 11 acá,
me va a quedar algo de la forma "y" es igual
a algo por "x" más otra cosa, que es justo
lo que queremos, despejar a "y"
y por lo tanto voy a restar 11, y éste y éste se van y
encontes me voy a quedar con "y" es igual...
y de este lado derecho me va a quedar,
5 veces "x", éste se baja...
5 veces "x" menos 1, porque si te das cuenta
10 menos 11 es -1.
Y justo aquí ya tenemos la respuesta, "y"
es igual a "5x" menos 1,
¡Y ya está!
de lujo, porque es el momento de sacar el
navegador de internet
que lo tengo justo por aquí
y es hora de poner la respuesta.
"y" es igual a 5 por "x" más... y bueno, como aquí tengo el más voy a poner un -1,
de tal manera que más por menos sea menos y ya,
justo aquí está mi respuesta.
Vamos a comprobar que la respuesta esté bien...
Y de lujo, estamos bien.